in the last few minutes the prosecutor
has revealed that wayne cousins
uh handcuffed and arrested sarah everard
before putting her
into the back of his car
and driving her off to rape and murder
her and ian that really
solves one of the big puzzles
of this whole case about how
sarah everard
a very bright and intelligent marketing
executive was persuaded
to get into the back of cousin's car
as she walked home along the
busy south circular road
last march
the prosecutor
has also quoted her boyfriend
describing sarah like this she was
extremely intelligent savvy and
streetwise
not a gullible person the prosecutor
said it was inconceivable
that she would have got into a car
without being coerced or manipulated
the prosecutor has also suggested very
strongly that
wayne cousins used the enforcement of
the covid regulations at the time
to
stop sarah and then arrest her
and we do know that
on the night
she was abducted by cousins she had she
was walking home at about 9 30 on the
3rd of march but she'd been to visit a
friend
of hers for dinner
at the friend's house
in apparent breach of the regulations at
the time remember this was during the
third lockdown
during march before
the road map had been set out
to get out of the lockdown
all social meetings were banned at the
time
the prosecutor said that
wayne cousins
in the days before this abduction had
been working on covid patrols he knew
what to say to somebody breaching the
covid rules
the prosecutor has also said
that there were occasions when cousins
would take home to his home and deal his
police belt and handcuffs and he often
did that not against the regulations but
he often went to training sessions at
other locations from his normal
workplace in south london so it wasn't
unusual for him to take them home but
there are witnesses said the prosecutor
who described seeing cousins in the days
before the abduction
wearing his police belt when he was out
walking his dog
and indeed shopping
now
away from court i've been talking to
simon harding a former detective chief
inspector
who played a leading role in the sarah
everard investigation and i met him at
the scene of sarah's abduction
and i asked him about
how it was that wayne cousins was able
to persuade sarah to get into the back
of the car this is what he said
a witness saw sarah being handcuffed
now for somebody to get into the back of
a car with a
essentially a stranger
albeit is might have a police badge
without doing anything wrong
it would take someone like sarah
probably not to get into that car she
probably wouldn't have got into the back
of that car the only reason that i can
think of in my experience as a police
officer is that he's had to get her into
that car somehow and the main way to get
her into that car is to put her under
arrest and one of the witnesses that has
come forward in that inquiry that they
found
said that they saw sarah being
handcuffed
he could have made up a law he could
have said anything he wanted to to get
her into the car i mean he could have
used covid as a as a reason to get her
into the back of the car and said you're
breaching covered rules and
arrested her you know sarah wouldn't
necessarily known every single law and
he could have made one up to get in the
back of the car
the prosecutor is giving a lot of
details
particularly about wayne cousins
movements
and actions in the days ahead of
the abduction he said at one point that
cousins had joined a dating
app
on
on the internet
claimed to be a single
man and had had some contact
with an escort
woman
the metropolitan police ahead of uh this
hearing has put out a very brief
statement and it said this
we are sick and angered and devastated
by this man's crimes which betray
everything we stand for our thoughts are
with sarah's family and her many friends
we recognize his actions raise many
questions and concerns but we will not
be commentating commenting further until
the hearing is complete
we expect the prosecutor to finish his
details of uh the actions
and events probably by lunchtime today
we may then get
something from
jim sturman qc
who is the barrister for
weighing cousins some mitigation we've
no idea what he's going to say and then
the judge is going to take the rest of
the day and overnight to consider his
sentence and he's already indicated an
earlier hearing that it's possible he
may give wayne cousins a full life
sentence
if not then it's expected there'll be a
very long
minimum sentence there's an automatic
life sentence
for his admission of the rape kidnap and
murder of of sarah everard but we won't
hear
the judge's final thoughts on the
sentence until tomorrow